good morning Hank it's Tuesday so as you
know we have a podcast dear Hank and
John or as I prefer to think of it Dear
John and Hank and on that podcast I
recently confessed that instead of
pouring milk on my cereal I use water
now not quite there is generally a very
supportive community but their
condemnation of my cereal eating habits
was Swift and nearly universal people
said in scientific studies supposedly
proving you're supposed to eat cereal
with milk and then there was this vine
which recreated one person's experience
of eating cereal with water but along
the way Hank I when there is a secret
community of people like me out there
according to one study 13% of Americans
put coffee in their cereal another 12%
use orange juice I even heard of some
people who use lemon-lime Gatorade so
today I am going to taste test all of
the ways of moistening cereal which
cereal while I chose raisin bran because
it toes the line between healthy and
delicious I mean you know it's healthy
because it has brand in the title but
you know it's delicious because it has
more calories sugar and sodium than
Lucky Charms
speaking of which also picked up some
Lucky Charms cuz it turns out it's
healthy okay first off we have raisin
bran mixed with delicious safe American
tap water note when we say from
delicious in certain jurisdictions ah so
good I just love raisin bran with water
it is delicious others just absolutely
magnificent 5 reasons next up we're
gonna mix our raisin bran with some
Florida orange juice no no no two great
ingredients that when mixed together
just turn out horribly for me the orange
juice is one raisin out of five even
that's a little generous ok up third
raisin brand with lemon lime Gatorade in
general I'm a big Gatorade fanon because
I just had the orange juice it was so
much better by comparison that it was
almost good but it still wasn't good to
raisins out of five fourth up hot black
coffee straight from my AFC Wimbledon
mug in to the raisin bran I gotta say
for me this tasted almost exclusively
like coffee and not at all like raisin
bran but whatever I like coffee and it's
fine in brand form 3 raisins out of 5
and then lastly we have raisin bran
mixed with cow's milk ahh it's just
disgusting it's so rich it tastes like a
meeting cake or something I just that's
not breakfast I'm gonna give milk to
raisins out of 5
by the way surgical tool move
then Henry and I attacked it with a
clone army so there you have it heck
according to a scientific study of my
taste buds the best liquid to pour on
your Raisin Bran is water followed in
order by coffee lemon-lime Gatorade that
stuff that comes out of the nether
regions of a cow and orange juice now
thank you said on the podcast that you
tried cereal with water and you didn't
like it
you're a milk guy so we have an
intractable disagreement but I think
we're gonna continue to respect each
other and collaborate anyway and there
may be a lesson in that Hank I'll see
you on Friday